in the future everything will be 3d the
problem is today there are some things
that are not 3d like anything you might
want to watch on your TV and that's a
problem for the manufacturers of 3d TVs
because apart from a few blu-ray discs
and maybe some games there's not a lot
of 3d content that you can watch at home
they've hit upon the solution and that's
get you to make your own 3d movies now
behind me is Panasonic's 3d camcorder
it's last year's technology but they've
set it up in an interesting way to make
a demo of what you can do with your own
movies the 3d camcorder is pointing at
you and you're looking through 3d
glasses at a 3d screen so you can see
yourself in 3d it's really trippy now
part from really cool stoner demos like
this I think this technology shows
promise for taking 3d vacation photos or
home movies of your kids so I'm looking
forward to seeing how it develops in
addition to panasonic sony also debuted
a 3d handycam here at CES and other
companies like fujifilm and even
polaroid are going to be coming out with
their own 3d cameras so I look forward
to the future when everything is in 3d